le bas du jour les députés s'augmentent
de 300 € par mois pour leur frais de
mandat face à l'inflation êtes-vous
choqué are you shocking
euh alors c'est pas du salaire mais de
l'argent pour rembourser leur frais de
mandat fr de mandat voilà donc d'accord
je tiens à le préciser mais le timing
les beaucoup de gens disent que le
timing n'est pas bon 300 € par mois
supplémentaire pour des élus qui ont
déjà une situation privilégiée alors que
les agriculteurs sont dans la rue et les
Français qui n'arrivent pas boucler leur
fin de mois ça ne passe pas alors
êtes-vous choqué ou pas du tout est-ce
que vous dites c'est normal rapport à l'
d'abord écoutez celle qui qui n'a rien à
voir làdedans je tiens à le préciser n'
rien à voir làdedans et en plus je l'
trouv excellente vraiment je l'aime
beaucoup et elle elle a rien à voir
là-dedans voilà c'est la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale elle elle est pas
augmenté elle non voilà ah non non elle
a des frais de représentation de mandat
également elle a une circonscription
elle une permanence mais c'est pas elle
qui a voulu être augmenté pas vu
êtreugmentéendre les question
avant mer elle a justifié le sujet ce
matin regarde tout le monde a voté pour
j'ai eu de abstention pour être très
transparente du groupe la France
insoumise je comprends les mois que ça
peut susciter chez certains et cette
question a été évoqué cette cette est-ce
que c'est opportun de le faire
maintenant et nous avons convenu que
c'était opportun pour plusieurs raisons
il ne s'agit pas d'une hausse de la
rémunération des
parlementaires nous avons voter à
l'unanimité la hausse du plafond de nos
frais
j'aimerais d'abord alors le oui est
normal donc j'aimerais du non d'abord
j'aimerais
sair c'est plus original et j'espère que
vos amis de la France vont donner les
300 ball tous les
[Musique]
mois pas de que tu races en
une alors c'est pas beaucoup
de 17 sur 19 il y avait 19 votants 17 on
dit oui deux se sont abstenus la
FR par
sa bon Guillaume Janton sal bon déjà
déjà on l'a dit 300 € par mois de frais
c'est pas 300 € par mois de salaire
c'est un petit détail mais c'est
toujours ça avoir les noms parce que je
veux savoir pourquoi il dis ensuite les
députés moi je pense que ce n'est pas
n'importe qui ce sont des gens qui sont
élus qui ont des rôles importants
puisquils doivent voter les lois et je
pense que la réflexion est malsine parce
que au lieu de de souhaiter au députés
de ne pas être augmenté on devrait
souhaiter à tout le monde d'être
augmenter et ne pas tirer sur les
députés les Français
sou che qui critiqu ça il y a une forme
de comparaison avec tout le monde et on
souhaiterait quelque que les députés ne
soi pas augmentés là où les Français les
autres Français dev être augmentés je
comp unputé un salarié lambda ça relève
de la démagogie et il y a surtout une
une hypocrisie là-dedans c'est que tout
le monde souhaiterait augmenter nous les
premiers et nous les premiers on a pas
besoin d'argent et on prendrait une
augmentation ils ont bien raison de la
prendre l'ugmentation attendez attendez
attendez attendez attendez s'il vous
plaît pas tous en même temps on aura
Jean-Michel on va voir Jean-Michel je
voudrai des noms pour l'instant parce
que les noms c'est c'est c'est bizarre
de dire non donc j'ai envie de savoir
pourquoi oui tu as raison de dire non
mais c'est pas une augmentation de
salaire c'est gens là ils vont pas
pouvoir partir en vacances aller au Club
Med Gy je ne sais quoi c'est l'argent
qui sert à payer
non non c'est pas l'argent des
collaborateurs il a 11000 € pour les
collaborateurs trajets loation
per tout il faut justifier chaque
centime et l'argent qui n pas dépensé il
le rendre sur la dernière législature il
y a eu 10 millions d'euros qui ont été
remboursés par les députés l'argent qui
n'était pas
dépensément
sal le problème c'est pas qu' c'est pas
le salaire c'est trop de députés en
France voilà il y aurait moins de
députés ça choquerait personne sauf que
là il y a trop de députés par rapport à
la population française il a beaucoup
plus que dans tous les autres pays il y
a une surprésentation du nombre de
députés c'est pour ça que ça ça ça coûte
beaucoup d'argent mais les 300 € c'est
d'être populiste que dire que c'est ils
sont mettre pas plein des poches faut
justifier chaque centime chaque euro
donc franchement c'est rien de aussi
pour alors on va arrêter avec
l'hypocrisie les frais de représentation
c'est du salaire ils se coupent les
cheveux avec ils mangent avec ils font
tout avec finals de les prendre toi
alors je suis pas député non mais moi
moi ça ne me choque pas que les députés
s'augmentent déjà je trouve qu'on a trop
de députés je voudrais qu'on ait un peu
moins de députés et surtout nos députés
sont très très mal payés quand on
regarde le le travail qui est fourni en
taux horaire c'est très mal payé la
plupart étaaient cadres avant c'était
des CSP plus qui gagnaient bien plus par
contre ce qui est choquant c'est qu'il
le fassent en cette période en cette
période de forte inflation les mecs font
une loi une loi pour lutter contre
l'inflation mais uniquement pour eux
voilàah donc donc
change de finir laisser finir à mais non
mais mais Valérie moi moi je Cho
question êtes-vous choqué qui s'ugment
non ça me choque pas je alors j'aimerais
avoir j'aimerais avoir Daniel Mor parce
que je suis étonné qu'elle dise oui ah
ben si je suis choqué bah évidemment
c'est scandaleux c'est surtout une
question de famille 300 € excuse-moi il
y a il y a énormément en ce moment on
entend que des témoignages
d'agriculteurs qui tou 800 900 € par
mois excuse-moi quand tu me parles de tu
dis qu'il faut qu'il soit bien payé
parce qu'ils font beaucoup d'heur les
agriculteurs à ce moment-là ils auraient
la p des députés excuse-moi donc en fait
c'est la c'est un tiers de ce que
gagnent les agriculteurs hier bon je
peux finir connerie attendez je peux
finir quand même tu finis une connerie
ça sert à rien hier annoncer ça hier
alors que ça fait quand même plusieurs
jours que le que le feu coue c'est
vraiment mettre le feu au poudre depuis
ce matin j'entends des agriculteurs qui
disent ça nous conforte dans notre idée
d'aller à Paris déjà que la plupart des
ministres vivent entre le 6e et le 5e
arrondissement on sait tous qu'ils sont
complètement déconnectés c'est ce genre
de chose c'est un symbole évidemment 300
€ c'est rien c'est un symbole et je ne
comprend même pas qu'ils aient pu faire
une erreur comme ça excuse-moi finir
laissz finir mamie déjà elle fait quand
elle parle longtemps c'est très bien le
dentier s'écle donc voilà donc laissez
laà c'est c'est juste une histoire de
symbole et c'est une erreur mais de
débutant et je suis désolé quand demain
les agriculteurs seront à Paris il ils
auront ils auront ça sur la conscience
c'est ridicule don senconnexion c'est
vrai mais
rien il faut qu'il soit bien payé parce
que il travaillent énormément parce
qu'il y a énormément de gens qui
travaill beaucoup on des salaires de
misère donc c'est pas c'est pas une
excuse et en plus l'argument aussi de
dire si on les paye mal ils feront autre
chose mais c'est scandaleux parce que si
on paye les infirmières mal elles vont
faire ton sou tu vas nous faire un B non
mais en plus j'ai pas Macron là qui peut
te pas Macron sous non mais moi je vais
prendre exactement les mêmes les mêmes
arguments que toi mais sauf que du coup
je suis
parce que parce que effectivement il
travaille énormément effectivement cet
argent il va comme tu le dis Jean-Michel
être décompté centimes par centime et si
si à la fin des fins bah ils ont ils
n'ont pas tout dépensé et ben ils vont
le rembourser je suis d'accord avec toi
mais simplement en ce moment il y a des
une manifestation avec des des
agriculteurs qui nous expliquent à
longueur de plateau qu' gagneent 400 €
par mois en travaillant 90 he par
semaine et et et et est-ce que
franchement c'était le moment de dire ça
aujourd'hui de faire ça maintenant de
voter ça
maintenant mais non c'est pas une
histoire de
démie jeis d'accord avec ce que tu dis
je
disination la politique c'est aussi
desbf es ma
calme-i ton discours est plein de bon
sentiments dans un monde idéal bien sû
là tu vas maintenant tu vas faire tes
PMF le samedi dimanche tu vasre augmenté
tu plus que les députés donc vas-y où
est la logique c'est
[Musique]
pas j'ai pas négocié du tout mon
salaire m'a proposé j'ai dit oui j'ai
Mme pas par j'ai
parl
mais
leag
t un démago de service qu' rappor est-ce
que je suis est-ce que je suis une élu
de de la République et est-ce que je
suis en train de dire et est-ce que je
suis en train de dire devant les
Français je vais je vais
m'augmenteras pas besoin de demander
augmenté
automatiquement alors s' vous plaît
j'aimerais juste qu'on de petites
minutes et qu'on arrête de parler de
cette augmentation qui n'est pas du tout
validé non mais je vous le dis ça re un
package c'estàd on va travailler plus
moins non mais c'est l'inlation parce
que normalement non mais parce que
quelqu'un disait travailleer plus pour
gagner plus non moi je dis travailleer
plus pour gagner autant parfait bravo
Chef Chef